[Music]
[Applause]
bill guillory covers the pelicans for
the athletic kind enough to join us this
morning thank you will um how's the
video going over of zion's dunk within
the uh pelicans organization
uh my twitter has certainly been noisy
that's for sure it's a lot going on uh
people are very excited that they got
conspiracy theories going uh it's just a
normal day in zion williams chilean
that's for sure okay
now i've i thought maybe he's just
saying i want to play i can play because
i this can't be part of his rehab will
where they said hey we want you to do a
vince carter dunk it's
you know shooting jumpers maybe running
around a little bit maybe some drills
there
but is is there a different message
being sent or delivered that the
pelicans maybe are going to shut him
down where it felt like zion was saying
i can play i want to play
yeah i mean when zion came back to new
orleans i think his intention was to at
least prove or at least try to prove
that he can play this season and you can
understand from the pelicans perspective
where they will want a slow play plan
because there's been several setbacks
this season when they've tried to ramp
him up and get him closer to playing
he's he's got gone as far as doing three
on three uh four and four and practice
and then the soreness and the foot
started kicking in so they had to slow
him down so once he comes back from
portland you can understand why they
wouldn't say hey we're just gonna throw
in three on three games and see how you
do so they've tried to limit his
activity and practice the only thing
i've seen him do you know in media
availability after practice is stand
still shooting in dribbling drills on
his own
uh so i don't think there's been any you
know part of the drill where you throw
the ball off the backboard and put it
between your legs and dunk it i think
that's part of the rehab program but the
guy is obviously gifted i think he wants
to show that he can still play this
season but i think when you just look at
the calendar there just isn't that much
time left for them to get him into
practices get him into physical contact
so i can understand what both sides are
coming from if you're a player you want
to play but if you're the organization
you want to protect your asset
do you think zion williamson is a
pelican in three years
i think so i i think they're gonna try
to find a way to get that deal done this
summer and once those guys sign those
contracts you know after the rookie deal
assuming it's somewhere close to a max
contract it's usually around year four
uh where you know the grumbling start to
happen especially a guy that young i
don't see them trading him
year two into a five-year contract but
does he want to be there will does he
want to i go back to the draft
you know just seemed like he was
disappointed the lottery
i think the biggest thing for us is are
they going to win and i think the the if
you look at that team last year and what
they were doing with stan van gaal
india's head coach uh eric bledsoe
stephen adams in the start lineup it
just wasn't working the the vibe in the
locker room was really bad and i think
now with willie green coming in cj
mccollum the newest addition brandon
ingram emerging into a potential
all-star
i think you see this thing moving in a
much better direction the the feel
around the team is much better i think
they're in a much better position to win
once zion williamson is back so i think
if he's back and they're winning games i
think he's going to see him much happier
but as long as they're losing and he's
not playing it's under that
understandable why he wouldn't be happy
with what was going on but i think
they're going to be in a much better
position next year once he's healthy and
they can finally put all those guys on
the court together what is his status
there's 10 games left
do we see zion williamson at all the
rest of this regular season
i mean i find it hard to believe just
like i said there just isn't much time
left i don't even have that many
practices left to even get him you know
ramped up like i said as of right now
the only thing he's allowed to do at
practices is stand still shooting and
dribbling drills so that's you know not
any contact there's not any running uh
not any five on five you would assume
before they put him in an actual nba
game they will want to get him into some
five and five activity right uh so i
think there just isn't that much time to
do that uh so i would be highly
surprised if he plays again this season
uh but i think they're gonna try to
continue to progress him and see what he
looks like because they want to sign him
to a new deal this summer there's no
question about that they want to feel
comfortable about giving them all that
money uh but i think throwing him in the
game you know with this little time left
on the calendar without that much
practice time i i think i'd be a little
bit reckless
will good to talk to you and uh gives
you something to write about something a
little bit different there with uh zion
williamson but thanks for joining us
i appreciate you helping me out then
there's always something going on that's
the show yes it is will guillory he
covers the pelicans for the athletic